hi everyone welcome to this exciting
session by simply learn
today we have a really interesting topic
for you
in this video we'll be discussing about
the hypothesis testing
we'll start by talking about the
hypothesis testing and how a research
question can help you come with a good
hypothesis
then we'll look at the hypothesis and
the criteria for developing a good
hypothesis
following that we'll look at the null
hypothesis concept test statistics and
understand it with the help of an
example
finally we conclude this video by
briefing you about the significance
level
so let's get started
what is hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing or significance
testing is a method for testing a claim
or hypothesis about a parameter in a
population using data measured in a
sample
the purpose of the hypothesis testing is
to check if there is enough statistical
evidence in a favor of hypothesis that
we have claimed
now we will move on to the research
question
a research problem is a broad issue that
you would like to address through your
research
it identifies the difficult doubt or
area of concern in the theory or in
practice
that requires thought and investigation
research objectives are clear statements
of what you aim to achieve through your
research there are specific actions that
you will take and act as a milestone
that will help you complete your
research a research question is a
specific concern that you will answer
through research it is derived from a
research problem but is based on a study
design
when you narrow down on a research
problem to a specific idea that points
towards a feasible way to investigate or
address the research problems we'll get
a research question
now
what you should really take care of is
the slight difference between the
research question and the hypothesis
hypothesis makes prediction about
experimental outcome whereas research
question does not
let's understand with the help of an
example suppose your research question
is how many hours per day a student
spends on a giving and you want the
answer for that
another recent question may be
do the college students with more study
hours can achieve the higher gpa than
the students who do not put in more
hours for study
these questions can be answered by
framing a hypothesis so let's understand
what a hypothesis is
a hypothesis is a temptative statement
about the relationship between two or
more variables
it is a specific festival predictions
about what you expect to happen in a
study the hypothesis is a prediction but
it involves more than a guess
most of the time hypothesis begins with
a question which is then explored to a
background research
hypothesis translates the research
question into a prediction of expected
outcomes
unless you are creating an explanatory
study a hypothesis should always explain
what to expect to happen
so as in the previous slide we have
framed the question that how many hours
per student spend on a gaming related to
this question we can create a hypothesis
that students who spend more time on
gaming are socially alienated
so there are some good criteria for a
good hypothesis let's discuss what are
those
a hypothesis should be compatible with
the current knowledge in the area and it
should follow the logical consistency it
should not be inconsistent in places
a good hypothesis must be shaded briefly
and clearly
and it should be testable now we'll
understand what a null hypothesis and
alternative hypothesis is
the null hypothesis is the assumption
that an event will not occur
a null hypothesis has no bearing on the
study's outcome unless it is rejected
h naught is a symbol for null hypothesis
the alternating hypothesis or a research
hypothesis is a logical opposite of the
null hypothesis
the acceptance of the alternative
hypothesis follows the rejection of the
null hypothesis
let's understand the null hypothesis
with the help of an example suppose we
have a research hypothesis the duration
of an advertisement on the tv channels
is positively related to the sales of
the product
the more the duration the more the sales
of that product
so the null hypothesis of this
assumption would be
the duration of the advertisement on the
tv channels are not related to the sales
of the product they're not related at
all now we'll move on to the test
statistics that i frequently discussed
when creating hypothesis testing
the test statistics is a number
calculated from the statistical test of
a hypothesis it shows how close your
observed data matches the distribution
expected under the null hypothesis of
data statistical test
the distribution of the data is how
often each observation occurs and can be
described by central tendency and
variation around the central tendencies
the test statistics summarizes your
observed data into a single number using
the central tendency variation sample
size and the other number of predictable
variables in your statistical model
there are broadly three capsule
statistical tests
different statistical tests have
slightly different ways of calculating
these test statistics but the underlying
hypothesis and interpretation of the
test statistics stay the same
so the first one is a t-test
a t-test is a statistical test that is
used to compare the means of two groups
it is often used in hypothesis testing
to determine whether a process or
treatment actually has an effect on the
population of interest or whether the
two groups are different from one
another the null hypothesis
is that the true difference between
these group means is zero and the
alternative hypothesis is that the true
difference is different from zero
now let's move on to the test
the tests are statistical way of testing
a hypothesis that either we know the
population variance or we don't know the
population variance but our sample size
is greater than 30. we perform the z
test when we want to compare a sample
mean with the population mean
the next is an f test the f test or the
f statistics is simply a ratio of two
variances
variances is a measure of dispersion or
how far the data are scattered from the
mean larger values represent a greater
dispersion despite being a ratio of
variances you can use a f-test in a wide
variety of situation
f-test can assess the equality of
variances however by changing the
variances that are included in the ratio
the f-test became a very flexible test
now that we have discussed all the
theories related to the hypothesis
testing let's take an example to
understand them more clearly
consider a study on a group of students
whether students receive a special
learning aid to the online videos on
science
it is hypothesized that after viewing
these online videos the group of
students who are better than the one who
have not seen the videos
so in this case a research hypothesis
will be students who have received their
special science learning videos will
score high in a science competency test
and its null hypothesis will be the
special science learning videos may no
impact on the scores of the students
now we will discuss what a significance
level is
level of significance or significance
level refers to a criterion of judgment
upon which a decision is made regarding
the values stated in the null hypothesis
this criteria is based on the
probability of obtaining a statistic
measured in a sample if the values
stated in null hypothesis were true
generally the criterion of the level of
significance is typically set at 5
or 0.05
this value of significance level can
also be taken as one percent or 10
depending upon your requirement
if the result obtained from the study
indicates the probability lower than the
significance level so in this case a
researcher can reject null hypothesis
otherwise if the result of the study
indicates a probability higher than the
significance level the researcher can
support the null hypothesis with that we
have come to the end of this video on
hypothesis testing i hope this was
helpful
if you have any questions then please
put them in the comment section also
if you like the video then please
subscribe to the simple channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
thank you for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here